welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and thor love and thunder has given
us new gods to pray to several tears of
them ranked by increasing order of
from jacked ass guardians to dad bod
olympians to three faced golden statues
even more mouths to do whatever they
want with me with
i just want to be one of those grapes
this new chamber showing the statues of
marvel cosmic entities the living
tribunal the watcher death eon and
infinity and specifically that last one
actually begins to explain why jane
foster was powered up into the mighty
thor and why mjolnir is back in its
current reassembled yet still cracked
state this movie is going to have all of
us asking who we pray to and what we
believe and what i believe is that when
we pray to any god we are praying for
one of two things for love or for
thunder a god's loving mercy and their
blessing on those we love or a god's
vengeful thunder to punish the wicked
and deliver us from evil you could also
categorize this as new testament versus
old testament but i don't think you want
sunday school classes from a mephisto
worshiper one of my favorite shots from
this new love and thunder trailer is
when jane rescues thor from the olympian
guards by swinging mjolnir and
unleashing a cluster of its broken
pieces which is such an interesting
range attack move that nearly duplicates
the effectiveness of mjolnir if you
consider each broken piece to be equally
as impactful and empowered by mjolnir's
magic as the hammer as a whole so when
jane wields his hammer it is not fully
reforged back into a monolithic uru mass
it retains its shattered structure each
piece bound together and capable of
releasing in a spray and then retracting
to its source if you think about it this
really reflects jane's character
development in this film tekka waititi
is adapting jason aaron's mighty thor
comics in which jane is diagnosed with
cancer and wields mjolnir which allows
her to temporarily power up into an
asgardian god but whenever she depowers
she resets her chemotherapy treatments
therefore mjolnir is not a permanent fix
to her problems the cancer is still
there and in this movie mjolnir is not
permanently reforged it still retains a
mix of strength and fragility jane's
health condition is one thing the promo
footage has avoided thus far it makes
sense marvel studios wants to sell us on
an escapist thor adventure with new
tears of godly might and atheistic
brutality in which thor faces an
ex-girlfriend doing apparently way
better than he is and one thing i love
about this rom comedy premise is that
any time we stumble across exes in real
life or on social media they seem to be
crushing it but really what we are
seeing is our own heartbreak and
unresolved issues with that person
reflected back on us and we fail to see
the truth that everyone everyone is
going through private struggles fighting
secret wars that they do not share with
the rest of the world trust me it's not
a contest between you and your ex they
are feeling just as cautiously confident
and straight-up panicked as you are and
for jane foster to reach this status of
mjolnir worthiness trust me she has had
to suffer her journey into deification
wasn't just being worthy of mjolnir i
mean if mjolnir worthiness was all that
took steve rogers envisioned would have
gotten asgardian armor when they wielded
it no this was a grueling rite of
passage in a mixed blessing of love and
of thunder from the gods of this
universe and mjolnir was a side effect
of that deeper transition now i'm not a
skin care aficionado but i prefer my
face to not look like i've been lost in
the dunes of tatooine i want to take
care of the money maker well the fine
folks at geology have hooked me up with
some skincare products that i have loved
geology is a nine-time award-winning
men's skincare company that creates
simple effective personalized skincare
products for men so click the link in
the video's description and take a 30
second quiz tell them about your skin
and their teenage dermatologist designs
a regimen just for you that shifts
directly to your door it's great for
folks worried about acne dark eye
circles wrinkles signs of aging they
send you a 30-day trial set that's easy
to incorporate into your routine whether
you're new to skin care or seasoned
expert here's what they sent me everyday
face wash repairing night cream vital
morning face cream and some nourishing
eye cream so far today just using this
everyday face watch has just made my
face feel more comfortable on my head
like i don't have that awkward like
the tightness that sets in in the middle
of the day it just feels like my skin is
like a nice blanket on my body i don't
know if that makes sense to you but i'm
just like aware of my skin now and it
feels nice really by designing these
things i love that they do the thinking
for me they send me just what i need and
i just have to use it and they are
offering a crazy deal right now you can
get 70
off on their 30-day five-piece trial kit
so head to geology.com to get 70 off on
your 30 day trial kit when you use the
promo code or just click on the link
below that's geology.com promo code
rockstars70 to save 70 off on your 30
day trial so what was that real change
well we have speculated that the cause
of jane's cancer may have been her
exposure to the reality stone ether back
in thor the dark world the ether called
out to her with a cursed voice and she
was infected with it and it nearly
killed her and even though it was
extracted we know the infinity stones
leave derivative traces of gamma
radiation behind even after they're
removed this radiation is how carol
danvers became captain marvel and many
of us believe similar radiation exposure
to monaco rambo photon may have led to
the cancer that killed her mother maria
rambo during the blip now adventures in
game implied a pretty problematic
subplot with jane foster in the ether
with rocket extracting it from her off
screen during the time heist and steve
rogers at the end of that movie
returning each stone from the point in
history it was taken meaning he had to
somehow reinsert the ether back into
jane's body so if jane's cancer comes
from that reality stone ether that would
be so severely cruel to the character
especially when it considers steve
rogers restored history by making sure
she was stuck with it there's just a
deeply cosmic imbalance to that beyond
it being a weird logical loose and end
game only discussed in nerdy youtube
videos and that brings us to these five
cosmic entities jane now faces in this
chamber in the trailer the living
tribunal the watcher death eon and
infinity in a few videos i've speculated
these could represent a higher tier of
gods the gods to the gods the ones
figures like celestials appeal to to
settle their disputes these could also
be what odin and heimdall have called
the all fathers or in the comics what's
referred to as those who sit above and
shadow the source of the bifrost magic
and the magic that powers mjolnir jane
powers up mjolnir in this place so it
stands to reason these five entities are
at least connected to it but the
inclusion of infinity in this lineup is
interesting now infinity is the sister
to eternity eternity is the living
embodiment of the universe itself both
have actually appeared depicted in the
mcu before in the morag temple wall art
showing infinity eternity death and
entropy in a circle surrounding the
infinity stones it is believed that the
entity infinity was the source of the
infinity stones if for brother eternity
is the living boundary of the universe
infinity would be the source of the six
singularities that embody the constants
that bind it together space power
reality soul time and mind and when one
of those stones was used to cosmically
doom one woman and for that woman to be
the linchpin scapegoat who must bear the
burden of those stones playing their
crucial role in the avengers loophole
subversion of fate and endgame that is
exactly the kind of greek tragedy plight
that a god like infinity might take
mercy upon that her stones named after
her did this therefore i think the love
of love and thunder maybe the mercy
infinity takes upon jane foster infinity
being the cause of jane's condition and
infinity being the answer to her prayers
so i imagine infinity lobbying the
living tribunal and the other cosmic
entities to stage a divine intervention
on jane foster and provide a legal
remedy for two cosmic imbalances left
after the infinity saga jane's condition
and mjolnir's shattered state that i
believe is how jane will be elevated to
god's status a promotion i imagine only
the gods of the gods could enact and why
they selected her to be the bearer of a
newly reassembled mjolnir but a hammer
whose brokenness remains etched into its
form so yeah i don't know if it's as
simple of a narrative as well jane
picked up a mjolnir that fixed itself
and now she looked into becoming the god
despite that nice perk not coming to
vision and cap i think it's the other
way around jane was blessed into god
status to spare her from a sickness the
infinity saga cruelly punished her with
and that because of that blessing she
can now wield that same cosmic magic in
ways others have been able to with a
semi-fixed mjolnir love being jane's
healthy body and viral strength a
respite from her cancer thunder being
the reassembled mjolnir that she can now
do some really cool [ __ ] with let me
know your thoughts on this theory and
you can support new rock stars by
checking out our merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos following
the rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
for more announcements everything you
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you